this is the worst day by far we've just
come from the outside back into the camp
we've been there for a few hours it is
utterly utterly horrendous it is boiling
hot people have been queueing in their
thousands and they're now coming down
the road all the down the road
to um containers big
cargo containers that are that are
designed to funnel the people uh down to
the right-hand side and mainly down the
left-hand side
but people at the front are being
absolutely crushed and we believe people
have died
this morning
i've seen a lot of people getting
medical attention
the shout for medics and for stretchers
is almost continuous at the same time
there's
blast explosions which are designed to
frighten the crowd to try to get them to
push back uh firing in the air trying to
get people just to take a step back
there's children being pulled out up
over the cargo car the sea cargo
carriers and and brought down where
medics are trying to treat them as well
it is utterly horrendous the
number of the soldiers i've spoken to i
mean they're not in panic that is
completely the wrong description
it is very very tense they're doing
everything to try to
keep some order but also to rescue
people who are in danger of dying or who
may well be dying we believe they are a
number of the senior soldiers that i've
spoken to say that these are people who
have done multiple tours of afghanistan
saying it is the worst thing they have
ever seen in their entire careers in the
military now this is this is not to be
taken lightly because we are talking
hardened combat soldiers who saying you
know we we can control what's going on
in terms of saving people at the front
but we don't know what's going on behind
and there is no way they can get to them
and i you know what the worst thing
about it i can't see
how really this is going to stop until
they basically say that's it
close the doors and leave and tens of
thousands of people who are in this
street will just have to leave most of
those people will not qualify uh to come
through to any country other than
afghanistan under the current systems
and i can't see any system is going to
just sort of open up the gates and just
keep flying people out uh forever so at
some point there will come a time where
they say enough is enough there are lots
of legitimate uh british nationals but
also people with legitimate rights to
come to the uk
to united states to canada and to a
number of other countries as well but
they just can't get through uh
eventually they sort of make their way
through and they're in a hell of a state
when they get here it is quite the most
amazing thing i've ever seen
a lot of it we decided we did film but
eventually the soldiers were saying
you've just got to stop and you've got
to withdraw because they were they
it was pandemonium they're having to
bring up uh reinforcements all the time
because in front of the in front of the
um
the crate
for a better expression is a row of
paratroopers who have got riot shields
they don't
they're not just hit anyone or to to
stopping it's just a sort of human
barrier to stop the people just
literally coming through and climbing up
the cargo carriers which you know they
would have to stop
but that the funneling entrance and you
know we know with any type of funneling
it it causes a backlog but this the
pressure is so high and there is no way
that that pressure can get released so
people probably the first 50 meters are
in terrible state terrible condition and
there's just nothing people could do
they're spraying water on them from
above as best they can
with hoses
and as i say doctors
nurses just continuously running to the
front being people out
looking at them
on the ground treating them there if
they're okay then they treat them a
little longer and then they let them
wait the effect of that means is that
you have the huge crowd outside
you have the paratroopers uh in the
middle you have the people coming
through they're then put into if you
like a triage area which is between
these these crates um but they're not
likely to be people with the proper
paperwork so what they're going to do
with them they don't know so they've now
had to create another line
of of paris uh again with shields to
stop them coming through because if you
go beyond that then you move towards the
united states and other countries who
are processing their people because it's
all pretty much descended on this
section of the airport
and they are
working on those people but they're
trying to stop them getting through so
pandemonium not chaos but really really
dangerous and very difficult